For the 3rd time,
the UN voted overwhelmingly to end the war in Ukraine.
Here's all the countries that voted yes.
I know what you're thinking, Dave.
The UN can't just vote to end the war, right?
You're right.
Russia doesn't take this vote into account.
They voted no, by the way.
But 2 other countries voted no that hadn't before.
And India abstain from voting again.
Their trade with Russia,
which includes imports of oil,
has reached all time highs
since the invasion of Ukraine.
China abstain from voting
and has positioned itself as neutral.
The Kremlin says that China's president
is visiting Russia soon.
With that all said,
you might be wondering,
does this vote even matter? Matter?
Today is the one year anniversary
of russia's invasion of Ukraine.
While these votes cannot directly affect the war,
they give us a good idea of how major world powers
are feeling about the war going forward.